це ж ти в морі ким і моєму провини
гніздиться оптимальні визнаємо не
основою для подалі та роботи з фгос
канали
олег кардинально змінювати колір та кабани
стало тому, що це
нас цінних конструктивні шлях і
c заклик д ну до вершини альмування
робіт to the way націй творче процесу
столітті була запатентована і дикі
успішно торгує з правницею цпш інші ж
я хотів би сказати або кут багато
правильно сказав ще частка закону про
світла вона ніби заляже і вигляд консенсусу
різних політичних сил у парламенті
червона знавці хотів би на око і таємно
там ще може займати і крайні позиції
політичні сили у парламенті чи всьому
є червоне лінії б поза червоне лінія
йти повз і право нападу ти
дружин аполітична сила в парламенті все
чи не з тусується
випробувань застосування і видно у мене та
по ширині застосування української мови
rytp і видно статті 10 конституції
україни а я на одну це можу осіб і
протягнув українською витримавши на йому
вікових арештовуються у всіх сферах
публічно жити на всій території
України
ось сем це я та й ліжок повинен ходити і
перекопуємо на зуби вливають з mist
шкірних законів